este vídeo quisiera probar algunas de
las propiedades básicas del producto
punto y bueno podrías encontrar qué es
lo que hago en este vídeo es algo
mundano y sabes para ser franco es algo
mundano pero lo hago por dos razones una
es que este tipo de cosas se preguntan
usualmente cuando tomas una clase de
álgebra lineal pero lo más importante es
que te da la precisión de que realmente
estamos construyendo una matemática de
vectores desde cero y no podemos asumir
nada necesitas probar todo por ti mismo
así que lo primero que quiero probar es
la conmuta actividad es decir el
producto punto es conmutativo y para
esto no voy a tomar dos vectores el
producto punto debe punto w
esto es conmutativo es decir b punto w
es lo mismo que w punto b pues vamos a
escribir los vectores así que lo primero
que voy a hacer es definir estos
vectores voy a decir que el vector b lo
voy a poner aquí es el vector b1 b2 b3
hasta b
con entradas tenemos este vector este es
el vector b y bueno el vector w
voy a decir que es el vector www3 w4
hasta w n con en entradas también tiene
este vector así que vamos a ver quién es
de punto w primero de punto w
es igual recordando la definición que
vimos la vez pasada es la multiplicación
de la primer componente de b por la
primer componente de w ya esto le
sumamos la multiplicación de la segunda
componente de b por la segunda
componente de w y esto las grabamos y
todo esto y después terminábamos
sumándole la multiplicación de la
componente n del vector b que multiplica
la componente n del vector w y bueno
tienes w.va bueno vamos a usar la misma
definición y entonces me queda que esto
es lo mismo que doble uno por b 1 w 2
por b 2 déjame escribirlo más w3 por b 3
más llegar hasta llegar a w n
en la suma de todo esto y ahora si
queremos ver que estos dos son iguales
entonces tendrá que probar que estos dos
términos que tengo aquí son iguales es
decir que veo uno doble uno es igual a
doble uno por b uno y la respuesta es
que esto es cierto porque al final tanto
de uno como doble uno existen en los
números reales y en los nombres reales
si se cumple la propiedad conmutativa de
hecho déjeme escribirlo aquí la
propiedad conmutativa de los números
reales con muy conmutativa si déjenme
ponerlo bien conmutativa de los números
reales es justo esta propiedad w1 por b
1 es lo mismo que b uno por doble uno
pues recuerda que esto está definido en
los números reales y entonces va a ser
lo mismo para w 2 b2 b2w 2 y así hasta
bn w n que es lo mismo que w x b n y
esto acaba de probar que entonces esto
si se cumple es decir la propiedad
conmutativa en el producto punto sirve y
funciona muy bien ahora qué pasa con la
propiedad distributiva se cumplirá y
para esto déjame definir 1
héctor voy a definir el tercer vector y
bueno creo que ya sabes cómo lo voy a
definir esto es lo mismo que x 1 x 2
hasta x en este es mi vector x y ahora
yo lo que quiero ver es qué pasa si yo
me tomo la siguiente operación voy a ver
qué va a pasar cuando yo tengo w más veo
ve más w así que déjame cambiar un poco
de color y ahora sí voy a escribir
entonces el vector b más el vector w y
esto producto punto con el vector x y
bueno al final date cuenta que ya
probamos la propiedad conmutativa y por
lo tanto esto sería lo mismo que ponerle
x al final como está aquí escrito o la
equis en un principio es decir x punto
la suma de estos dos vectores y yo
quiero ver si esto de pura casualidad es
igual a b el vector de punto x ya esto
lo voy a sumar el vector w punto x será
esto cierto
es decir se cumple la propiedad
distributiva en el producto punto y pues
vamos a ver para esto lo que necesito es
tener mucho cuidado con mis cuentas voy
a calcular primero cuánto es el vector b
más
w aquí lo voy a poner el vector b más el
vector w es igual a quien a pues esto
también es un vector es el vector b 1 +
w1 es la primer componente en la segunda
componente b2w 2 y así hasta bn w n en
la nba componente bueno esto es el
vector de más el vector w y si a esto le
calculo su producto punto con el vector
x es decir x 1 x 2 hasta x n que me va a
quedar
bueno pues usando la definición de
producto punto es la primera entrada del
primero es decir b 1 + doble 1 que va a
multiplicar a la primera entrada del
segundo x1 ya esto le sumamos la segunda
entrada del primer vector que multiplica
a la segunda entrada del segundo vector
es decir b2w 2 x x2 y así hasta sumarle
la multiplicación de la n a la entrada
del primer vector que multiplica a la
nueva entrada del segundo vector bn + w
por equis n y bueno y bueno no sé me voy
a olvidar que esto es la suma de el
vector b más el vector w
le calculamos el producto punto con el
vector x esto es en primer lugar ahora
yo quiero buscar cuánto es de punto x +
w punto x para ver si llegamos a lo
mismo y ve x es lo mismo por definición
del producto punto que ve uno por x uno
más b 2 por x 2 + b n por x n sumamos
todas las multiplicaciones las
correspondientes entradas y que nos w
punto x a pues eso es doble 1 por x 1 +
w 2 por x 2 más hasta llegar a w x x n y
si ahora sumamos estos dos vectores
resultantes que me va a quedar si yo
obtengo la suma de b x + w punto equis
voy a obtener el lado derecho de esta
igualdad que me gustaría probar así que
vamos a ver esto me quedaría y déjame
escribirlo aquí b punto x + w x y esto
es igual a punto x que era b 1 x 1 ya
eso le voy a sumar doble 1 que
multiplica x 1 y a esto le tengo que
sumar las siguientes dos
multiplicaciones es decir b 2 x x 2
2 x x 2 + y así hasta sumar de la última
que 'se vende' por x n más w x x n y
bueno fíjate bien aquí está ya casi
probado lo que yo quiero porque si en
este primer sumando este primer sumando
grandote yo factor hizo a x1 como
estamos hablando de los números reales
yo puedo factorizar a x1 y si lo factor
hizo me va a quedar de una más w uno que
multiplica a x uno más de dos más w 2
que multiplica x 2 factor izando el x 2
y así voy a seguir actualizando todas
las x hasta llegar a b n más w n que
multiplica x n y qué creés esto es justo
lo mismo que teníamos aquí arriba es
decir estoy probando que esto y esto de
aquí es justo lo mismo como llegamos a
los mismos resultados después de que
factor izamos las x es entonces me queda
que ve más w la suma de vectores y esto
punto x es lo mismo que ve x más w punto
x y es decir que la propiedad
distributiva también se cumple en el
producto punto cuando hablamos de esta
multiplicación
del producto punto de vectores y bueno
yo sé que esto es tan mundano y tú te
vas a preguntar por qué estamos haciendo
esto pero estoy haciendo esto para
mostrarte que estamos reforzando cosas
simplemente no podemos asumir esto y de
hecho yo me salte la conductividad y la
distributiva y that cuando hablaba de la
suma de vectores y la multiplicación por
un escalar un lote de libros de
matemáticas o libros de álgebra lineal
deja esto como ejercicios para el
estudiante porque bueno pues porque es
mundano es decir para ellos no vale la
pena ponerlo a su papel pero bueno
permítanme mostrarles sólo supongo la
última propiedad asociativa la propiedad
asociativa que quiero mostrarles a
continuación voy a tener una constante
que multiplica a un vector y esto punto
otro vector acaso esto es lo mismo que
la constante que multiplica al producto
punto de estos dos vectores pues bueno
vamos a ver si yo tuviera la constante
que multiplica un vector recordando lo
que esto significa me quedaría por ver 1
c por b 2 y así hasta hacer por de n ya
esto le voy a calcular el producto punto
con el vector
y usando la definición del producto
punto esto me va a quedar como cb1 doble
1 más c por b 2 por w 2 más
así hasta c por b n por w
n esto es el lado izquierdo de esta
igualdad y si yo quisiera probar que
esta igualdad se cumple entonces déjame
checar qué va a pasar con el lado
derecho de esta ecuación de punto w esto
es lo mismo que ve 1 www2 más hasta b n
por w y si a esto lo multiplicó por c se
es una constante es un número escalar
entonces que me va a quedar pues bueno
ya que escribirlo aquí sé que multiplica
al producto punto debe punto w y bueno
entonces ésta se me quedaría
multiplicando todo esto y si te das
cuenta la c cumple la propiedad
distributiva como estamos en los números
reales la se va a cumplir que se puede
abrir a cada uno de los sumandos y
entonces me va a quedar se ve uno doble
uno más
se ve 2 w 2 + c y así hasta sumar se ve
en w que es exactamente lo mismo que
teníamos aquí a la izquierda y entonces
esto también se prueba acabamos de
probar otra propiedad del producto punto
se cumple la asociatividad cuando
hablamos de una constante ahora la parte
más difícil de esto que encuentre cuando
el profesor tendrá que asignar ya sabes
una prueba de esto y me refiero a la
primera vez que tome álgebra lineal es
que tenía problemas para hacerlo porque
era casi tan ridículamente obvio que
bueno no veía bien cómo encontrar la
demostración de este problema yo decía
es que obviamente basta con mirar las
componentes de ellas después tenemos una
constante una multiplicación por
componentes se cumple la asociatividad y
ya quedó esto es obvio pero el problema
es que anotar esto tal vez no sea tan
fácil cuando ves esto por primera vez y
es que al final los profesores no
querían que les resolvía el enigma de la
vida solamente querían que escribiera
todo esto y esto lo vamos a utilizar en
el siguiente vídeo en donde vamos a ver
propiedades mucho más interesantes sobre
operaciones de vectores